was macht der korona impfstoff mit den
menschen hatte nebenwirkungen ist er
wirklich gut verträglich der kinderarzt
steffen rabe aus münchen hat da auch so
seine zweifel hast du dir einen aus der
mediziner hat kein problem mit dem
impfen an sich aber bei den corona
wirkstoffen hat auch er große bedenken
und darüber redet er auch öffentlich
alle wichtigen fragen zum kugel im stoff
sind noch offen
wir wissen nicht schützt die impfung vor
schweren verläufen schützt die impfung
die diebe schützen wollen nämlich alte
und vor erkrankte wie lange schützt die
impfung wir müssen den menschen sagen
dass das schon einen experimentellen
charakter in einer notfallsituation hat
experimenteller charakter
weltweit wurden bislang mehr als 150
millionen impfdosen verabreicht die die
studien belegt haben
bis zu 95 prozent schutz vor einer
erkrankung bieten können
raabes thesen die er auch als sprecher
des vereins ärzte für individuelle
impfentscheidung nach außen vertritt und
viele menschen erreicht trifft bei
vielen seiner kolleginnen auf
unverständnis
wir wollen von steffen rabe wissen woher
seine bedenken kommen ob er überhaupt
jemals erfahrungen mit impfschäden als
praktizierender arzt gemacht hat
mir sind keine kinder gestorben oder
durch impfungen schwer erkrankt ist seit
30 jahren in meiner kinder heilkundliche
praxis und habe nie wirklich extrem
schwere nebenwirkungen gesehen aber es
gibt sie menschen können auch durch
impfungen zu schaden
in deutschland werden sogenannte
verdachtsfälle auf nebenwirkungen und
komplikationen dem paul ehrlich institut
gemeldet im zuge der chor ohne impfung
kam es im beobachtungszeitraum bei 1000
impfdosen in lediglich 0,1 fällen zu
einer schwerwiegenden meldung wie
beispielsweise einer narbenbildung an
der einstichstelle die eine
krankenhauseinweisung zur folge hatte
für den kinderarzt ist derzeit klar er
wird sich nicht gegen das corona virus
impfen lassen habe sich mit seinen 55
jahren weder als risikopatient noch
überzeuge ihn die neuartige technologie
da dürfen noch einige jahre ins land
gehen bevor ich diese impfstoffe selber
für mich in anspruch nehmen würde wir
reden unverändert über eine erkrankung
die bei 85 bis 90 prozent derer die sie
bekommen unbemerkt oder harmlos verläuft
aller hysterie zum trotz wir reden nicht
über ebola wir reden nicht über die pest
wir reden über eine erkrankung die die
meisten die sie bekommen gar nicht
bemerken
hier machen sie tagtäglich aber ganz
andere erfahrungen
wir sind im klinikum rechts der isar der
technischen universität münchen auf der
chor wird intensivstation
dort treffen wir die stationsleiterin
caroline von ritter zarooni kaum einer
ist dem virus so ausgeliefert wie die
krankenschwestern und pfleger seit nun
einem jahr erleben sie hier welche
folgen eine ansteckung mit dem corona
virus haben kann
dass es immer noch so viel wut und
zweifel in der bevölkerung gibt macht
sie traurig neben krone leugnern ist es
jetzt vor allem die kleine aber sehr
laute gruppe der impfkritiker innen
ich halte mich ehrlicherweise
mittlerweile von socialmedia relativ
fern weil ich werd unfassbar bieten
ich kann nur einfach nicht verstehen was
da passiert ist also wo genau hat die
information nicht ausgereicht bzw wann
genau war es einfach logisch etwas
völlig absurdes zu glauben und nicht
fakten und tatsachen zu glauben umso
erstaunlicher auch die impfskepsis beim
medizinischen personal selbst noch im
dezember zeigen umfragen dass sich nur
jede zweite pflegekraft impfen lassen
möchte
auch bei karoline von ritter und ihrem
team obwohl sie tagtäglich im
ausnahmezustand arbeiten und näher an
der pandemie und den folgen dran sind
als die meisten menschen
oh man so schön dich zu sehen
ich mache einmal deine hand hoch
es scheint bei bildern wie diesem schwer
vorstellbar dass die intensiv schwester
selbst anfangs große vorbehalte hatte
wenn man natürlich innerhalb eines
dreiviertel jahres einen impfstoff
heraus stampft ohne jemals damit in
kontakt gewesen zu sein ist natürlich
der zweifel da ich kann mich an anfang
dezember erinnern wo nahezu jeder gesagt
hat nerven in der ersten charge auf gar
keinen fall mache ich nicht also kommt
nicht in frage
von 35 mitarbeitern waren es gerade mal
zehn die sich impfen lassen wollten auf
anderen stationen sei es sogar noch
schlechter aus erzählt sie es gibt sogar
pflegekräften skeptiker und ich glaube
das kann man einfach damit erklären dass
wir einfach auch nun querschnitt der
masse sind
das ist halt einfach so und ich glaube
in jedem in jeder großen gruppe in jeder
großen vereinigung gibt einfach den
klassischen querschnitt und dummer
mensch ich empfinde eine repräsentative
studie zeigt dass impfgegner in allen
gesellschaftlichen gruppen vertreten
sind knapp ein drittel aller impfgegner
gehören dem sogenannten liberal
intellektuelle milieu an
dazu zählen menschen mit einem generell
höheren einkommen und bildungsniveau
laut studie hinterfragt diese
gruppierung dinge auch erst mal kritisch
getreu dem motto um die herdenimmunität
können sich erst mal die anderen kümmern
die gruppe der impfgegner so komplex sie
auch ist sie wird größer
das besorgt auch den nordrhein
westfälischen innenminister wir sind in
einer zeit wo die menschen unsicher sind
weil es eine gefahr gibt ja als crooner
und dass menschen dann empfänglich sind
für ideen warum das so ist oder warum
man das nicht richtig bekämpft und wer
daran schuld ist und damit das potenzial
ganz schnell zu organisieren ist dass
man menschen aufwiegelt und es kann
passieren dass man politische bewegungen
erzeugt die man nachher nicht in griff
kriegt
warum scheint das thema derart politisch
aufgeladen
das ist ein ganz neues phänomen in einer
ausprägung wie wir ja zehn tagen oder
jahrhundert nicht mehr gehabt haben und
das führt zu unsicherheit und
unsicherheit ist der nährboden für
demagogen und verschwörer mit
verschwörungs ideologien beschäftigt sie
sich seit jahren die sozialpsychologin
pia lamberti ich kann aus meiner eigenen
forschung sagen dass man schon sehr sehr
stark sein kann dass der verschwörungs
glaube mit einer starken ablehnung von
impfungen einhergehen verschwörungs
glaube ist es ja so dass alle die die
als mächtig markiert werden also die
pharmafirmen die medizin die
wissenschaft die sind das feindbild und
da passt es natürlich auch das impfung
oder insgesamt medizinische ansätze
abgelehnt
weitere studien zeigen zudem dass ältere
menschen eine impfung deutlich positiver
gegenüberstehen als die jüngeren frauen
sind mit nur 61 prozent impfbereitschaft
generell die größeren im skeptiker
während zu beginn der pandemie vor allem
im netz und auf der straße mobil gemacht
wurde verteilen um skeptiker seit
einigen monaten flugblätter die
verbreiter von solchen desinformation
verschwörungs erzählungen ist der
vorteil dass man eben darauf nicht
unmittelbar reagieren kann dass das eben
menschen kommt die vielleicht auch älter
sind die nicht wissen worum handelt es
sich hier
und soeben ängste aufgespürt werden
vielleicht gerade in der zielgruppe die
die impfung besonders dringend nötig in
marburg treffen wir frank michel
er verteilt solche flugblätter warnte
darin vor einem impfzwang und zensur
durch den staat
michler ist teil der initiative
weiterdenken marburg kandidiert zudem
für das amt des oberbürgermeisters
organisiert wie er selbst sagt den
widerstand ich habe keine sorge dass wir
in ein autoritäres gesellschaftssystem
abgleiten
viele weichen jetzt leider in die
falsche richtung gestellt werden ich
habe keine angst vor diesem virus aber
ich merke in vielen menschen deswegen
große angst gemacht wurden ist vor
diesem virus ich fahre ja auch auto
jedes mal wenn ich mich ins auto setze
riskiere ich mein leben und ich riskiere
sogar dass ich das leben anderer
zerstöre das heißt das risiko einer
erkrankung ist ungefähr so groß wie eine
frage mit dem auto ich kann das jetzt
nicht direkt digitalen vergleichen aber
es ist beides ein risiko das man
eingehen aber anders ich haben eine
pandemie da sind ja schon über zwei
millionen menschen insgesamt weltweit
gestorben
es sterben jedes jahr sehr viele
menschen an allen möglichen anderen
krankheiten
seit neun monaten verteilt er nun die
flyer die szene in marburg wächst es
gibt unzählige gruppen in den sozialen
netzwerken vor allem auf messenger
diensten wie tele bärn in fast jeder
größeren stadt gibt es protest gruppen
und die vernetzung passiert sehr schnell
wenn ich es nach darmstadt auf eine demo
war und dann dort mit menschen sprechen
und tauschten telefonnummern aus
telegramm kontakt und schon gibt es die
vernetzung zwischen marburg und
darmstadt mobilisierung im netz
verbreitung von flugblättern auf der
straße es ist eine neue strategie einer
bewegung die jetzt auch auf alte
kommunikationswege setzt der analoge weg
lässt sich viel schlechter zensieren und
der digitalen welt gibt es am ende
wirklich massive zensur welle wo die
großen marktbeherrschenden digital
konzerne wirklich eine krasse zensur
machen youtube-videos werden am
fließband gelöscht mitten im shutdown
trifft er einen bekannten auch er
verteilt flugblätter kämpft gegen die
korona maßnahmen
als biologe weiß mich ja genau das ein
virus ansteckend ist und krank machen
kann
für ihn ist corona aber kein
medizinisches phänomen sondern ein
politisches dass der unterdrückung der
bevölkerung diene
ich habe angst dass und zwang aufgebaut
wird das durch diskriminierung von
menschen die nicht geimpft sind im druck
aufgebaut wird dass sich menschen impfen
lassen die sich eigentlich nicht impfen
lassen wollen und dagegen wehre ich mich
und dagegen kämpfe ich nicht alle mögen
in ihrer haltung so radikalisiert worden
seien aber viele menschen fühlen sich
verunsichert die immunität aus weiß ja
oder nein impfpflicht für alle für
keinen oder nur für das pflegepersonal
in den vergangenen monaten kam es immer
wieder zu einem politischen zickzackkurs
die gruppe der überzeugten impfgegner
könnte jetzt vor allem durch die neu
aufgetauchten virus mutationen zu einem
wirklichen problem werden
das besorgt den gesundheitsexperten der
spd karl lauterbach
gefährden die impfgegner dass man die
pandemien griff bekommt wir haben am
anfang immer gedacht es wurden 60
prozent geimpft erreichen also
möglicherweise mit diesem neuen
varianten nicht ausreichend von daher
würden dann die impfgegner
möglicherweise ein problem darstellen
wenn wir in die aus herdenimmunität
durchimpfung kommen wollen
auch wenn seit dem start der kurve
schutzimpfung im dezember die
impfbereitschaft leicht gestiegen ist
würden sich derzeit etwa zehn prozent
der bundesbürger auf keinen fall impfen
lassen
rund 20 prozent sagen sie seien noch
unsicher während karl lauterbach auf die
vernunft der zweifler hofft hat er die
radikalen impfgegner schon lange
aufgegeben
für diejenigen die die impfung kritisch
hinterfragen sind wir jederzeit offen
die kleine gruppe der radikalen entgegen
und der ideologisch also sein mal
festgelegten leute die werden wir durch
argumentationen und überzeugung nicht
erreichen
es gibt einfach keine diskussionen auf
der grundlage einer verschwörungstheorie
ich kann zum beispiel nicht hingehen und
jetzt meinetwegen auch somit impfgegnern
darüber sprechen also ob bill gates oder
herr soros oder was auch immer
hier plant über eine impfung die
menschen sich gefügig zu machen habe ich
euch bereit zu sprechen die
verhältnismäßig kleine gruppe der
radikalen impfgegner wird auf der straße
und im netz dafür umso größer und lauter
und organisiert desinformationskampagne
eine der auffälligsten die kampagne
ärzte für aufklärung ein zusammenschluss
von ärzten und medizinern die vor einer
zwangsimpfung und möglichen 80 tausend
todesopfern durch die impfung warnen
ihre positionen verbreiten die mediziner
seit monaten bundesweit auf flugblättern
wie diesen auf demonstrationen und im
netz wir wollen wissen wer diese ärzte
sind und nehmen kontakt zu ihnen auf
bitten um ein interview
wir erhalten viele ausreden ich habe mit
dem flyer nichts zu tun und absagen
keine objektive berichterstattung
also fahren wir direkt zu den ärzten im
impressum ist von walter weber die rede
ein arzt der seit monaten mit
provokanten behauptungen für aufsehen
sorgt dass eine gentechnische
manipulation frau merkel gibt also die
deutsche bevölkerung der pharmazie als
labor raten zur verfügung
trotz mehrfacher kontaktaufnahme bleiben
die türen verschlossen die von weber und
seinen kollegen vor laufender kamera
möchte keiner der mediziner von ärzte
für aufklärung mit uns sprechen
wir fragen uns müssen ärzte die
gefährliche thesen wie diese öffentlich
vertreten und viele menschen auch die
eigenen patienten möglicherweise
verunsichern nicht zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden in einer solchen
nationalen notlage können wir das nicht
tolerieren dann muss eben derart sich
entscheiden ob er hier eine
verschwörungstheorie propagiert oder ob
massa zweiter tätig ist dann müssen
diese kollegen hat einfach schlicht
ergreifend die approbation entzogen
bekommen dann sind sie nicht mehr
gefährlich
[Musik]
ob das wirklich so einfach geht wollen
wir von der ärztekammer wissen
vollumfänglich distanziere ich mich von
diesen flyern und nicht darf auch dazu
sagen dass all diejenigen jedenfalls die
unter unser berufsrecht und unter unser
aufsichtsrecht fallen unter beobachtung
stehen
und diejenigen die sich eben nicht an
die kowitz beschränkungen oder
verordnungen halten werden von uns auch
berufsrechtlich sanktioniert und zwar in
form von geldstrafen bis zu 50.000 euro
oder berufs gerichtsverfahren gegen
kampagnen wie die flyer habe die
ärztekammer wiederum nach eigenen
aussagen wenig in der hand diese
flugblätter sind für mich so am rande
des straftatbestandes das bild das kind
das sg impft wird und heult ja und
vielleicht die eltern die dann angst
haben dass das kind in irgendeiner form
dann spätschäden davon durch die
irreversibel sind dann ist das etwas was
am rande dessen ist ja was eigentlich
noch mit meinungsäußerungen gedeckt
werden kann
auf der gofit station im klinikum rechts
der isar herrscht inzwischen leichte
entwarnung die patienten zahlen sind
rückläufig
in der belegschaft gab es
zwischenzeitlich ein umdenken kurz vor
dem jahreswechsel stehen für carolin von
ritter und ihrem team die ersten
impfdosen bereit mit dem verfügbaren
impfstoff verließ sie die anfängliche
skepsis
der grund war schon ein bisschen der
dass ich mich natürlich irgendwann dann
schon angefangen habe mit dem thema
auseinanderzusetzen und tatsächlich aber
auch gesagt 14 mal so peper durch und
wenn man sich das dann eben so
durchliest und sich ein bisschen damit
auseinandersetzt stellt man fest das ist
einfach die modernste forschung und
maßgabe ist aber bringt man dann auch
verständnis für den einen oder anderen
skeptiker auf man bedenkt wenn sogar sie
zweifel hatten es ist tatsächlich so
dass ich es auch so empfindet dass die
information viel zu intransparent ich
musste papers lesen um wirklich auch
eine valide aussage zu bekommen und
jetzt sage ich mal so nicht jeder mensch
kann wissenschaftliche studien lesen
oder sie interpretieren und verstehen
die krankenschwester hofft darauf dass
die menschen die noch zweifeln vertrauen
entwickeln vertrauen in die impfstoffe
und den schutz den diese bieten kann nur
hoffen dass das für uns bedeutet dass
die zahlen wirklich bald deutlich sinken
und man kann nur hoffen dass der
wirklich bald wirklich viel tut für uns
am ende zeigt die hitzige debatte
deutlich
die kleine gruppe der radikalen
impfgegner scheint immun zu sein gegen
überzeugungskraft und fakten die
mehrheit der zweifler die möchte man
noch erreichen
[Musik]
natürlich kann man an einer impfung
zweifeln und wir schulden auch eine gute
aufklärung in jeder hinsicht das ganz
klar und niemand soll sich impfen lassen
der nach all diesen überlegungen der
meinung ist das möchte ich nicht wir
haben keine impfpflicht und wollen sie
auch nicht an
gefährlich wird es aber dann wenn
ideologie dahinter stehen und angebliche
medizinische sorgen nur als vehikel
vorgeschoben werden
es ist zum glück nicht die mehrheit die
sich gegen die impfung wird das zeigen
ja auch die zahlen aber das braucht es
ja auch nicht sein um diese abläufe die
gerade hier auch extrem fragil noch so
ein zerstören also dementsprechend finde
ich schon dass man das ernst nehmen muss
dass auch eine kleine gruppe laut sein
kann dass auch eine kleine gruppe
schaden anreichern kann richten kann
jetzt ist es aufgabe der politik die
gruppe der zweifler zu überzeugen
vertrauen zu schaffen sonst könnten sie
das ganze im projekt gefährden
dennoch ist die impfung die beste chance
auf eine rückkehr in einen ganz normalen
alltag